tout cas c'est du teleux quoi et c'est
quand même moi qui le fait le mieux
dites-moi monsieur teley oui qu'est-ce
qu'il y a est-ce qu'on peut toujours
parler dans ce cas précis dans votre cas
de bande dessinée
ah je sais moi je sais pas c'est une
question qu'on me pose souvent ça me dit
ouais mais c'est pas de la photo si tu
fais c'est pas de la peinture c'est pas
de la c'est pas de la BD tout ça et je
sais pas moi ce que c'est mais tout quoi
c'est dû te les quoi et c'est quand même
moi qui le fait le mieux
Jean-François il est là retenez bien ce
nom par sa faute les cadres
traditionnels de la bande dessinée vont
craquer cette opération de minage se
déroule en trois états un la science de
clic-clac pour illustrer toutes les
situations du scénario de la bande
dessinée les copains et copines sont mis
à contribuer deux les photos sont photos
copiées chez le marchand de journaux du
quartier à Cachan dans la banlieue
parisienne
[Musique]
3 le coloriage pour rendre plus
agressive les scènes violentes et plus
douce les scènes tendres moi j'utilise
n'importe quoi tout ce qui tout ce qui
marque sur du papier je m'en sers je
sais pas je me suis servi de javel mais
c'est servi de
crayon de couleur de d'encre de de
gouache de
d'acrylique de je colle des trucs et des
images d'ordinateur des
je sais pas moi tout tout des pansements
des n'importe quoi des coquilles d'oeufs
des plumes enfin tout ce qui passe à
portée de la main c'est bon tout ce qui
peut faire une image c'est bon
au départ je me sers de photos mais la
photo ça sert comme comme un carnet de
croquis quoi ça m'évite de ça m'évite de
faire les croquis et puis après tout le
reste c'est
c'est là que c'est là qui arrive la
partie créatrice comme ça on dit c'est
très triste
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et c'est un peu comprend que il faut
qu'il faut qu'il y ait un bout de bois
avec une mine dedans pour qu'une émotion
est uniquement ça
notion c'est la vie à partir du moment
que quelqu'un fait quelque chose et
qu'il ait envie
si il a quelque chose s'il y a une
émotion en lui ben normalement elle
fasse quoi s'il a du bol un petit peu de
talent je sais pas quoi
un livre scolaire destiné aux élèves des
classes de 3e consacre un chapitre à
Jean Teulé si le début de la gloire
ensemble après seulement 5 albums et un
prix de la presse obtenue à Angoulême
pour bloody Marly tele doit tout à
Bloody Mary cette histoire sordide a été
un succès en librairie
première fille qui me rapporte plus
d'argent qui est mon coup maintenant
comme ça je peux l'embrasser sur la
bouche
[Musique]